I was 15 when I met him oh
16. yeah and then kind of just been
together ever since can we get a round
of applause for that like I think
for sure appreciate it I appreciate it I
mean could you not have it together
pardon could you not have heard it
together
I'm not a fan of Sharon and I know that
she's the same so to be fair we thought
it would keep it simpler and just be us
soon just [ __ ] do it
that's cute
uh what about you guys ever had a whole
face
um I attempted to and then I realized
it's just not for me
um
yeah that's pretty much it I don't want
to show anymore
can I ask how long it lasted because it
sounds like not that long
um it lasted for about two months but I
feel like it's not for the week
no yeah like I've attempted to before
but I just I think I fall in love too
easily with people
and also I don't like that feeling of
like being used or like someone's only
like interested in you sexually I think
that's so like ill
are you the sugar baby yeah I mean I
mean it's good it's good for money but
but isn't that like multiple people yeah
but it's more online the way I do it oh
okay so no physical yeah like usually
they're from America and they're just
real desperate to talk to like a girl
and yeah it's like Andrew Tates like
girls type stuff yeah they were just
like talking yeah literally like giving
them false hope giving them false
promises oh so you're manipulating
people to take their money
I would never do it with someone I
genuinely like like money is not
something that impresses me but if
someone's gonna give it to me
yeah I'm not gonna be like No [ __ ] I'm
trying to get paid
I know someone that I worked with that
Snell stopped working and she's she does
um she's like a Dominatrix and she she
does like pay picks or something like
that yeah that's literally it
you literally just called empathetic put
them down and it gets them off and you
hit them as well
in my life with my life and she's like
I'll ruin you like send me your savings
the girl that I know they actually asked
they asked that they actually asked her
to record them as they withdraw money
from their ATM yeah and um and she'll be
like a good boy those are the men that
do exist hiding in the closet I'm just
saying
um
so you try to help a short period of
time yeah I mean I did it like I did
like my one little hookup or whatever
and I was just like it wasn't even like
anything deep I literally yeah like a
little touch and I just didn't like that
feeling of
being used and I didn't I wasn't getting
money in return so yeah it was pointless
would you if you were getting money in
return
[Music]
I mean I don't mind being eye candy for
money but you just said if if it was
touching then it would have been okay so
that isn't just eye candy that is
exchange of money I guess I wouldn't
like have sex for money but I definitely
I don't know a song was like kind of
like touch up give you my I've been paid
for a massage before
getting my skills in London know how to
be eye candy especially if you've been
to like Mayfair clubs I mean I used to
be a promoter when I was like 18 19. and
as much as I felt bad for saying to the
girls like you know you're a bit
you know you're not gonna get in or
she's your friend's gonna have to pay
at the same time it's like you kind of
understand that you have all these
footballers and all these celebrities
and Rich business people paying 10 15
grand for a table why does their Club
differ from anyone else in Camden where
you can just walk in and not pay that
much so you have to do for some harness
you have to accept your account eye
candy at that point because you're going
in for free you're drinking for food is
that a whole phase that would be an eye
candy isn't a whole face yeah not really
when I was younger I'm still young so
wait pull your mat closer
I know you guys are sharing something
hard
um when I was younger would I have
called it a hoe phase no was I open to
exploring and did I date yes and so I
guess other people may have seen that as
a whole phase but I didn't see it as a
whole face I was exploring and also when
you go to buy a car you try out all the
cars first you don't just pick the first
car well except
I'm a Gemini so I ain't never gonna pick
the first car I need to try it
I mean I just I'm not very good at
choosing one thing straight away and
sticking to that one thing in that
moment and just being like okay I'll
have that kind of pop and that's even if
I go into the shop to buy a packet of
crisps it takes me a minute so how long
did uh the kind of whole face it sounds
like you're not you're hesitant to call
it a whole face but yeah because I don't
like to label why should we label it a
whole face I mean
why to describe
Yeah well yeah um how long did it last
um
well I was in a nine-year relationship
with my son's dad so it stopped then and
then it started again and then it
stopped and it started again I think in
between relationships like where I've
been like like total how much time would
you say a year total maybe like two
three months between yeah something like
that yeah we'll go with that two years
yeah hook up with that okay
in the 35 years I've been on this Earth
a year okay over the year okay de novel
what about you
I haven't had a whole face I've been
mostly in relationships almost back to
back I have experience but no never been
a hoe it's the same thing but that's the
same as not labeling it as a whole like
you were experienced I experienced what
I said I'm saying what I said it was
being like in total I've been in
relationships for about
10 years and I've only been single for
just a year that's crazy do you know
what I think P
what do you think I think that if you're
not this lady right here with a ring on
her finger you're stuck in the whole
face forever and until you get around
wait wait wait wait and it's in her face
can I just I'm so sorry to do this but
what stay in her face are we talking
sleeping with men or are we saying it
doesn't matter
because I've never met him even though I
was young I was 15 I was seeing loads of
guys at the same time I mean I didn't do
anything with him I didn't even hold
hands with them yeah but I was
continuously talking to loads of guys
this is what I'm saying but the thing
with me was it was from a young age even
like when I was seven my first boyfriend
I broke up with him because he had bad
grades you know when I was best friend
but like to cut to go back to like no
point is that the whole phase exists
that's your like as a single woman that
is your mission to get out of that area
in my eyes because if you're single you
can access the whole face anytime you
like like women have the power to be at
home minding their business and they can
just pull out their Rolodex and call
somebody and they know somebody's gonna
show up 100.
00
that's the same thing as you saying that
every man has the capability to kill
therefore every man is a murderer that's
so yeah and but you know what Jordan
Pearson says the same thing a dangerous
man is a good man a weaker man isn't a
good man you want a man to be able to be
dangerous but control it that's what
makes a great mess that's why a woman is
not a hoe because when she is
controlling this she's not at home
wouldn't you say that if a woman's
acting like a house she's a hoe yeah but
just because your single doesn't mean
you're a hoe I I didn't say nobody said
that no what he said that's what he said
as long as you're singing
what he was saying is is every woman as
we know we all have options we all have
options right so what he's saying is at
any given time I have the option to be
like you know what I want to [ __ ] so I'm
gonna press this thing and Power Ranger
man is gonna come through that's what he
was saying so in his mind it's like if
you're single you have the potential to
be in that whole face yeah everybody has
a potential no no I think okay I think I
understand so you're basically saying
like you might as well be a hoe because
you have the option too and you're never
gonna know yeah and that's up to you and
women have that freedom because we as
like I said we as men we would never
ever know wait wait can I just jump in
yeah would you say that is the option or
the power too because those are two very
different things I mean well she she has
the option to exert that power true yeah
why put the spin on it it's just because
I feel like if you're gonna go down that
whole path that's very different than
just having the option to kind of dip
your toe in every once in a while yeah
you got the option not that either one
is good or yeah I hate what you're
saying but then it falls into that like
language where it would fall under
dating oh I'm dating again you see what
I'm saying so it depends on the
intention and where you're doing it from
but that's why I also but that's why I
ask what we mean by her face because if
we mean by the whole face that someone's
sleeping around because if you're going
on a date and then on the second date
you're sleeping someone I would say
that's a whole phase but if you're
you're going on a date and you're like
actually on a second one you know I
don't feel that I'm gonna go on the next
day and the next day and the next day
I have a question for the girls did
anyone feel like they got anything out
of the whole face like a positive
experience
anyone I've got loads of money for it
what I got loads of money
did I guess what I did get out of it was
understanding myself and what I did one
and what I didn't want from like because
there's one thing being in a long-term
relationship I've been in long-term
relationships like my son's dad nine
years my last relationship with three
years I got a lot from them but what you
get out of it like quite quickly is like
your icks your dislikes your okay I'm
not gonna do that I don't actually like
that type of guy or I don't I I maybe
don't Vibe with this type of person so I
got a lot from that do you think that
whole phases make women more picky
[Music]
100 because then you can go through men
quite quickly and be like yeah no I
don't want to say do you think whole
phases make women less attached yes yeah
I don't have a yes or one million
percent so I don't know about that
actually actually I was on on my Endo
speaking to one of my best friends and
um she's slept with a few guys and she's
in a relationship but she and I and I
kind of speak to her about you know like
she we have a mutual understanding of as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible